day four russia has stepped up its
military advance as its troops enter
ukraine's second biggest city kharkiv is
situated in the northeast
near the separatist held regions of
luhansk and donetsk more than 400
kilometers from the capital kiev several
military vehicles have been seen moving
along a street in kharkiv city center
the regional governor says ukrainian
forces are battling russian troops and
warn civilians not to go outside
russian forces have attacked oil and gas
facilities sparking huge explosions on
the fourth day of its land air and sea
invasion of ukraine troops are trying to
take over the vasiljkev air base that's
40 kilometers southwest of kiev an oil
depot there is on fire after being hit
by a russian missile
[Music]
air raid sirens have sounded in kiev
minutes before a blast was heard the
city's 3 million residents have been
told to take shelter
with fears the battle will get close to
the city center a curfew has been
imposed until monday morning
hoda abdelkhami joins us live now from
nepro in eastern ukraine just get us
right up to date with all the main
developments overnight your time
well in kharkiv um i think that's where
the most significant development
happened in this part of the country uh
the uh russians according to the civil
administrator that
uh some russians uh vehicle light
vehicles have managed to enter the city
from the northeast they also blew a gas
pipeline which would mean that many
civilians would not have heating and it
is very cold at this time of the year um
it seems that the city from what we
understand is now surrounded from all
sides
by the russians and it's quite difficult
also for civilians to get out of there
those who are trying uh to escape now
these are the early hours of the morning
and certainly we're gonna hear a bit
more a bit later from uh the civil
administration there but they were
depicting uh quite a grim picture at
this moment and then if we move towards
the capital
kiev um this was it's under curfew since
last night saturday 8 00 p.m until
tomorrow monday 8 00 a.m
that the according to the government
that's
to try to pinpoint what they call the
saboteurs russian elements who would be
even dressing civilians trying to
in civilian clothes rather trying to
cause
chaos there there was heavy fighting on
the streets in many parts
of the city
there's also
another development in vasil kiev which
is south of
cave the russians have been trying to
get that area there is an air base there
uh according to what we just heard a a
gas storage facility or fuel storage
facility rather has been hit uh there's
also
we still have unconfirmed return but it
seems that there's some sort of
radiation also that's coming out what we
can see from what's going on uh is that
the russians are trying to hit the
infrastructure
of the country trying to make life
extremely difficult by hitting fuel by
hitting gas and by trying also south of
here in zapolica trying to reach a
nuclear plant there they haven't been
able to but that's according to the
military that's where they are trying to
head as we speak is the calculation do
we think harder for the russian military
that kharkiv is an easier target to go
after because it's
almost as far east as you can go before
you bump into the donbass region
well i think the calculation was also
that kharkiv is so close to the russian
borders about 40 kilometers from the
russian border a lot of people who live
there are ethnically russian it is a
country that had so a city rider that
had shown support
to russia in the past there's a lot of
commercial links between the two sizes
even family links between the two sides
and i think the russians were quite
surprised to see that that city
regardless of all these links has
actually put up a fight and is resisting
that advance um it's not by it's it's by
calculation that really that they
started that they wanted to use kharkiv
as some sort of a rear base and from
there maybe head south towards here
nipper which is a city that the russians
would like to take because during uh the
past years during when the separatists
had advanced all the way to the nipper
river well this city was sort of the
headquarters of the ukrainian military
and it was from here that they were
launching their attack to push back the
separatists the russians got bogged down
in kharkiv they got bogged down in
uh kiev and even in mariupol yes they
managed uh to surround marupal they
managed to take mitti polo but they are
not in maryupol they do not have that
port city under their control so
certainly the advance has been uh slowed
down by all of that
but it was clear that their plan was to
try to sort of surround the dumbass and
then from there have the separatists
push up all the way to the nepa river
potter thank you very much for abdel
khamid they're talking to us live this
hour from dinipro in eastern ukraine
where